gravity is widely regarded as an action
at a distance phenomenon
you let go of the spoon and it is
mysteriously pushed toward
or pulled by the floor gravity is also a
bit spooky
because it appears to go through things
an astronaut cannot hide behind a
gravity shield
because this invisible force goes right
through the barrier
indeed a prominent berkeley professor
succinctly describes our extensive
experience with gravity
and clarifies what a theorist is
required to explain mechanistically
so for example if you have the earth
there's a big mass here
and you have you with your little mass
here every atom on earth is pulling on
every atom of you
you're also pulling on it the amazing
thing about gravity
is that it goes right through things
richard muller
university of berkeley gravity is
seemingly supernatural
simply because we cannot see or touch
the secret agents mother nature uses to
do this trick
yet if we conclude that no physical
object came in contact with the skin of
the spoon
we are in effect simulating gravity with
spirits and explaining the occurrence
with black magic under the rope
hypothesis
gravity is not an action at a distance
phenomenon it is merely that we cannot
see or touch the entities that serve as
mediators
the electromagnetic ropes
briefly the rope hypothesis proposes
that all atoms are physically
interconnected
by a pair of anti-parallel twine threads
it is this invisible intangible dna-like
entity
that mediates gravity let's first
illustrate the basic mechanism proposed
by the rope model of gravity imagine
andy and bob competing in a tug of war
charlie comes over and merely places his
hand on the rope halfway between them
as far as andy and bob are concerned
charlie is inexistent
charlie cannot pull on bob at the same
time he pulls on handy
he either pulls on one or the other the
only way that charlie can pull on both
andy and bob
is by drawing the rope out of alignment
on a different axis
now let's visualize what the rope model
proposes happens between a cube
and a cylinder the gravitational
equation describes
that a cube is attracted to a cylinder
in direct proportion to their respective
masses
and in inverse proportion to the
distance that separates them
let's interconnect a select group of
atoms that constitute each of these two
objects with lines
to visualize the mechanism note that all
the atoms illustrated
are on the same axis
what happens to these lines when the
cylinder moves closer to the cube
what happens is that the lines fan out
they drift out of alignment and are no
longer on the same axis
under the rope model of gravity each
rope is now acting independently
we refer to the ropes that act
independently as effective
ropes the strength of gravity is a
measure of the number of effective ropes
which is inversely proportional to
distance
imagine now an astronaut in free fall
towards the earth
the universally certified gravitational
acceleration around 9.8 meters per
second squared here on earth
tells us that the astronaut's weight
increases the closer he is to the center
of our planet
therefore if we weigh him at two
locations in outer space the scale
nearest the earth will show a higher
reading we learn from this that weight
is location specific
there is a given weight for each
location
under the rope hypothesis every atom
that comprises the astronaut
is bound to every atom that constitutes
the earth
when the astronaut moves closer to the
earth the ropes that interconnect is
atoms to each atom that comprises the
earth
fan out the atoms that constitute his
body drift out on different axis
and act independently
summarizing at great distances the ropes
act as a single coaxial
and gravity is weak at short distances
the rows fan out and act
independently the gravitational equation
is a measure of the effective roads that
bind the number of units of mass
contained by each object as a corollary
this mechanism explains in passing
the second mystery mentioned by
professor muller why gravity goes
through things
this is inevitable if all atoms are
interconnected
an atom behind another one on the same
axis makes one of them irrelevant as far
as weight is concerned
like in the tug of war between andy and
bob
it is the decrease in distance between
objects that induces the ropes to become
effective the physical cause that
underlies the principle of equivalence
also comes into view
imagine a single hydrogen atom at a
given distance from earth
every atom that comprises the earth is
physically bound to that atom
therefore it doesn't matter whether the
atom is escaping from the earth
or falling towards it or whether it's
part of an elephant
or a feather the number of effective
ropes converging on that hydrogen atom
from earth at that location
is the same as a bonus
the rope model of gravity enables us to
understand why stars at the edge of a
galaxy
do not fly out and in fact travel just
as fast or faster
than those on the inside track a
phenomenon known as the galaxy rotation
problem if all atoms are physically
interconnected it means that all stars
are also
physically interconnected think of a
galaxy as a gigantic spider web
superimposed on all the stars that
comprise it
a galaxy is a rotating platform that
revolves like a carousel
the galactic magnetic field helps
guarantee its integrity
[Music]
you